hey what's up like he told me right
there
you know Vincent Bugliosi died nobody
told me no yes tried to get devastating
news the minute you walk into a radio
yeah but he wrote helter skelter - yes
right he was the Manson prosecutor but
when he wrote there were topics JFK and
when he wrote reclaiming history it was
it was from a prosecutor's point of view
so he understands how to analyze
evidence had to prevent evidence right
he was a psychopath we [ __ ] hand
wrote him 20 years to write that book
and wrote it hand wrote it and he
knocked out every conspiracy theory well
so he's just sitting there like a maniac
with notepads in his house but just
writing about conspiracy theories all
the time yeah and he did a good job with
it he knew how so he was saying like he
didn't the JFK conspiracy that everybody
has like he'd knocked it like he was
like he thought none of them were good
I've read a bunch of conspiracy stuff
and he felt none of them held up when
you looked at all the conspiracies he he
felt this is why they're all did you
feel like the official story held up I
think the majority of it yeah the
autopsies and all that should huh how
you throw your first Tonight Show no
these are the seventh oh okay good so
you nervous man these people are
watching it as I can see seven times
I'm not indicative though i watch
nothing so literally you can know yeah
yeah you do hear that you how Jack Paar
is yeah no it's uh it's been a bunch of
them so you're not nervous but you've
got that whole you know all right I'm
doing the show tonight energy yeah yeah
you know like when you go out and like
you're always fine and then right when
you go out you're just a little like you
just don't want to mess the joke up or
something like you know or get lost or
like you know whatever but that's why
you come run it and then the night
before make sure hey I saw you last
night I didn't see your set because I
left how did you how did it go cuz I
would always what I was doing at
tonight's show said a lot I would bomb
not not on purpose but it would always
be that one set where I just completely
ate my deck before I went on with
was the night before or two nights
before and I always thought that was
okay and it got out of the way my
confidence no not at all no I used to
always go look for a show like that I
would go specifically to get on a bad
show just to make sure you could get
through it you want to make sure you get
through it in the worst situation
because it'll never be as bad as this
right you think you could just slow down
and talk and sound like this is having
fun even though you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
the bed yeah yeah I did a an open like
beta I think it was like an open mic at
the creek in the cave last night except
I was doing the Jade skanks with Jane on
them like and then in between there was
open mic and I was like oh I just kind
of jump on that there's like maybe seven
people in the room so that was like the
going up and anyone alright so then I
was like being I got excited as they all
just actually just could be a good story
if it works there but it was nice to run
it with I mean that was nothing like
they were sure you're in silence
yeah and just brutal yeah sometimes it's
uh sometimes it's good to get it out of
the way I'm like you got the budget or
you get the bomb out of the way yeah and
once in a while but I just wanted the
the what's the Improv in LA and I would
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm do it it was crazy and
Baba dross should be there and I'd be
[ __ ] up there like just tired they
were the guys who at that time booked
Leto meetings on oh yeah they did it for
a while up until I knew them to like up
until Linna like was done I think yes
yeah they were there for quite a while
now when you bomb in front of them do
they kind of they go like oh I don't
know if after a certain point you just
knew that was part of it I do they
didn't care they were like nah they
wouldn't even Rob they wouldn't even
tell me what to run the material with
them they just want to see it the night
before did would you get hurt like the
first time you did it did you get
nervous and have to go to them and be
like it's usually not like that yeah
yeah you [ __ ] terrified cocada gonna
take the show the night before I'm gonna
look like excuses like I did a thing
here that I would never have normally
done and they usually laugh they usually
always like always laugh you panic yeah
it's a yeah you know I think comics
always think that with everything they
do you just assume you're about you're
about to get told you're fired from
something like you just like you know
anybody talk to you like you go to
comedy clubs doing other numbers are
they
we find are you happy or you like you
just and that's with this same thing you
see it I just tell my side as they work
good right everybody's happy with this
set like you're fine you know if one
little thing doesn't give a laugh you
just yeah you're very nervous about it
does that does it does that worry
increase as success for both you as
success goes up does the worry go up or
do you start to develop a confidence
where you're like okay I've established
something here we'll be alright I think
you have a confidence if I bombed it
like real bomb like you know we there's
been guys that have bombed hard that
would be bad but I mean you know you
could also give if it did it's like you
go talk about it
I want TV mean yeah yeah like you bombed
on late and I like mad like that would
be I mean you know I don't want it to
happen tonight but it's a I would say
that if it did happen tonight we would
probably ask you to come back in and I'm
trying to get something that no one
cares about but yeah they yeah you would
you just don't want to do that like for
its you want it to be a good showing and
you get in and out of there unscathed
yeah and Nate is also at Caroline's
tonight through Sunday it's 2 and 2 7 5
7 4110 he's got helium in Portland
Orlando a gig good nights and riley
which is a great club and the west palm
improv at the end so you pretty much on
the road every weekend every weekend
yeah i just i just kind of was doing
that for a while I slowed now now it's
time isn't it yeah I like I like I love
with the tourists kind of like they just
adding dates so I'm just adding days to
pay you know paid the mortgage and I
just want to do some more dates yeah
going out every weekend it's [ __ ] a
ruff-ruff it's the best though for
riding coming up with the new hour I've
learned that like on the road though
yeah it is because you're hitting
different audiences different eyes
you're just longer sets and you know
like when you're doing spots here is
always like 15 minutes so you gotta kind
of get in them you gotta be get in and
get out like quick you got to stay on
top of everything and when you're on the
road I mean you can really try some new
jokes you just have so much time and
it's I think you just build a new act so
quick I was talking to Maggie about it
too yesterday after the show and he was
like yeah cuz he's also like that
he's doing like three weekends a months
at this point he's going crazy on the
road you know but he was like you know
in order to stay ahead of the business
like that way you don't to be dependent
on trying to find a TV show or trying to
sell this or trying to like if you can
just get yourself on the road a lot for
a while you get the money you're writing
all the time like you're you're at least
developing your craft right yeah you get
your own and you're in control of it
you're in control that's what we are
very lucky with over like actors because
it's like I think about what they have
to like you just have to sit and wait
and hope someone caught there's nothing
you can do right I can imagine that
feeling too like there's nothing yet
that you can do to go like earn money or
be successful you'd have to just sit
hope an agent calls and says you have
this thing that hope they want you to do
it yeah yeah and we have like we can go
into auditions really but it doesn't
matter like I don't if this does this is
like icing on you know or icing on the
cake or that's not saying I don't it is
yeah but you don't say it is an extra
thing right yeah that's the case you
know the cake is the important part
theoretically but let's know a lot of us
just like the ice oh don't come to
desserts I'm bad say yeah the it's it's
weird that's why I do a lot of stuff
trying to always keep busy because it's
it's also a fear of falling into a hole
and knowing knowing you're gone like hey
if you're doing this and doing this and
doing this that like one of those things
somebody is paying attention to you even
if the other two you're terrible like
that that's the mentality a lot of its
fear-based and and these are an
acknowledgement to it there's an
audience in front of you it's like okay
I got another audience this weekend
they're gonna remind me that I'm
relevant Irish appears said something we
had him on a the UFC podcast and he was
talking about something I forget his
exact terminology but he was said
something oh yeah like I'm gonna I'm an
artist and I'm making a living doing
this I'm doing what I want to do an
artist with who's free to say I forget
how he phrased it but I was a [ __ ] that
was right like you forget sometimes like
yeah this is kind of what I wanted I
loved it man you know I gotta remember
that I'm like I don't remember what he
says the theme of it with every fear you
always kind of happen and his testicles
are
but he was right that was a great point
I remember the basic theme of it is is
like you're doing what you want to do
shut the [ __ ] up exactly right yeah you
know it's funny twos you can get like
trying to stay in front of everyone
being around and everybody seen because
it's easy to get lost like said either
out of the system completely you can
also get lost in front of people you can
get I mean I remember guys do Murtaugh
that used to be here like Tiger Claw
and it was like this known as just not a
good club like or whatever but people
would hang out flyers and all that and I
know guys that would end up going up
there and get spots and they would do it
and then you I mean you would almost
think they quit comedy and it was just
funny cuz you didn't know no one went to
ha so they they weren't running around
right the other clubs and they were
there they were working as much as
everybody else but you just assumed
they'd quit and there's a geared like
yeah they're still doing it and they're
doing good but yeah you know I don't
know you don't want to get like lost
like just in front of that you know I
was right outside even though you're
doing it as much as everybody else it's
yeah it's a different like a little bit
of a different road or I could almost a
different circuit but the same circuit
but it's not it is a weird when you see
guys okay that guy's still around like
oh yeah he does he does danger feels the
strip and all these like clubs I just
don't do yeah yeah and you forget like
oh yeah there's a lot of clubs in New
York that's just a Comedy Cellar
there's the stand which I like in there
do you work a lot of the places I I
guess the older I've gotten most of them
I think would would would give me a spot
if I called in and I've just basically
doing the cellar you're just stuck in
your ways you get stuck in your ways
it's I I get it you're a converging yeah
man let's get up early yeah yeah when I
come back I usually I'll do the stand
cellar East fill all is there long yeah
you know now go about some strip or like
Christine you know I'll do a bunch of
them Caroline's indeed here right now
laughing name all the clothes everything
what cash register I was only nineties I
think did you ever do know I went in
there one time it was one of the first
time when I first started to get to know
David tell I figure I was only 90 I
don't remember why maybe 95 I think he
was doing Letterman
and he was running around doing letter
in spots as I just have a weird memory
of talking to him briefly in catch a
rising star I never spent time there
Mike Sweeney who I think of our
Stewart's pecan and whatever or he wrote
for him for years was really funny he
was like the house emcee there but I
never went on a catch and Lewis friend
over it from you know it was the guy who
worked there yeah I think he booked
catch so a lot of guys who don't like
Lewis have hated him since I know where
it started yeah and this trip I don't
guess they moved the stage for Jerry's
special yeah but I I never go the comic
strip never did well is one of those
rooms that I would always Bahman yeah
[ __ ] ate my dick in the comic strip a
whole lot you did yes hey I've done I've
done bad day and I've had some great set
sir that was the last club of that I got
past it it was yeah the strip was the
last one I doubt thing when I lived here
I want to get past it every single Club
and then I left
but the strip was the last one did we do
it was it through Lucien or no no I
never did I did star
I did audition start start Mariah's her
name is yeah and she would go and uh you
know you should do a Monday night and
then she tell you your terrible and then
you wouldn't get past was she not nice
I've never dealt with her on that level
yeah she was yeah she wasn't uh I don't
think it was mean like I mean she was
you know look there's a smaller star
lummox I think star okay I don't think I
I'm not stalling her as I thought it was
I could be wrong but yeah she was a you
know I miss you you get so we have too
many white comedians it's like her we
have - oh yeah and then uh but I think
she'd to everybody something you don't
know there's a flood of people trying to
get on that stage and her job is to be I
can't let every like it doesn't she was
the door dilution at one point like you
would see her and then if she likes you
now it's not it's star I think it was
Starla try a different spelling I could
be wrong
Moran's like Jason Moran I just now that
he's got me thinking of her because I I
I kind of backdoored into this this trip
they never really wanted to pass me but
he reluctantly takes I want a contest
there but I never got great spots to you
never met him I don't think so I think
he was here I was here before he
we need uh yeah yeah I was here before
he died it but I think I've seen him but
I never like heading I don't have a
story or anything like yeah you still
like chain restaurants I feel like we
had a conversation a long time ago about
you being a huge fan yeah yeah I like
them I like everything they do yeah yeah
me too I and I'm glad you're coming in I
got excited this morning specifically I
remember a while ago I having a
conversation with him about love and
chain restaurants because these guys
always try to make me feel bad about it
Florentine comes in here and just acts
like it's the most insane thing ever
yeah Jim doesn't know I need a police in
Times Square unbelievable amounts of
times I mean Applebee's and they never
want to not that good it's so good TGI
Fridays at least the [ __ ] spinach and
artichoke dip okay right it does rule to
get something he's like yeah he starts
at Applebee's and they'll make you say
Friday all right I'll go fry no is we
know they're all the same thing like
okay Applebee's like I'm gonna [ __ ]
Applebee's like oh this is over here
this is over here well what about what
about Buffalo Wild Wings and they go
okay yeah it's unbelievable it's amazing
my favorite part about living in the
suburbs I live in Westchester yeah and
there is no fewer than four Buffalo Wild
Wings in driving distance from me you
should've got b/w threes that's B dubs
yeah is the whole thing I love it the
other time I didn t bag all [ __ ] up
will you will you eat McDonald's yes
yeah yeah I neither have no problem have
you know anything I'm getting older I'm
39 so it's it's I'm it's starting to you
feel everything so much more than you
did obviously everybody does so now it's
uh I've had to like calm down I've been
on like this green smoothie cleanse for
ten days oh yeah yeah there's like day
eleven dealing with the skinny sad thing
yeah being like skinny and still fat
yeah the green I'm struggling with that
in a big way right yes it's been pointed
out yeah a lot of people know well I
don't know a lot of people appointed us
I better start going back to the gym did
you yeah
or did you just say something no no
Jessie's I mean Jess's unbelievable you
think she might be blind she's
unbelievable tactile of availability she
could feel your little hips apparently
not because she doesn't say a word about
it that's not positive same as Amish
woman hips but I was like this is this
is starting again what made you realize
that what made you realize that you you
might have to do something I mean it's
been the last like several months every
time I look in the mirror it's just like
that's [ __ ] disgusting okay it's good
yeah you know maybe you weren't big
shirts though maybe wearing two shirts
well yeah I know yeah now I have to be a
little bit choosier about what I decide
to wear because I'm like that everything
is just so obviously some money they
come back here you go shopping with that
fat they just grab a shirt I got a not
only know what it's like just to be like
now literally any shirt like just there
grant yeah worth I don't care doesn't
matter like I went to that a few years
ago I look like I had AIDS but people
like you're too skinny but buying
clothes was [ __ ] amazing cuz you
didn't care they alright that looks like
I like that I'm gonna try it on oh yeah
no it's not afraid of anything it's
unbelievable I pick up a small shirt
like a small button down in front shirt
that I bought like you know a couple
years ago and just go like what the [ __ ]
was I thinking it's ridiculous but yes
but yet so but I still haven't I I've
realized that I can't stop like I don't
I'm not disgusted enough to change how a
meeting like yeah have you gone to the
gym I have no idea it's right I say okay
well if I still eat like [ __ ] but go to
the gym maybe I'll start to cancel out
run food what did you do it like what
did you how many days did you go I
didn't know I didn't know you're going
to the gym it's been a week and I've
about a wheel I got like I guess at the
end of last week into this week so it's
been like a week and it's been like
Sunday I guess was the first day it's
been about every other day okay yeah how
long do you offer sounds like 45 minutes
do like a you know a mile and a half to
two miles on the treadmill walking no no
run around yeah yeah work up a nice
sweat you know and then you got to work
up a sweat sure you know I mean you're
gonna you're gonna pump iron yeah and
then you know and then lift
a little bit but did you say to the
person in treadmill next to you yeah
you're running on the treadmill and
she's there take your headphones off
since 1977 no us at pumping iron right I
do yeah I'll do like a mile and a half
to two miles on the treadmill to start
and then a little bit of lifting but
then you know my arms get sore pretty
quick understandable you're a little
fella you know I don't wanna I don't
want to overdo it to look in first week
we're happier there right exactly that's
you know nice and slow
that's what I want ground tell people
I'm just happy I'm here yeah I think I'm
doing something like I never work out I
just end up talking to everybody what
did you do on the road do you do have
any return or on the road it's just
gotten so [ __ ] boring man yeah it's
uh that's where you got to go to Chili's
yeah but that's like drinking like
that's a stuff stop drinking right now
and then but it's cuz you just you get
in those like I had that you get in
those habits of like I mean you're just
like um I guess I'll drink like I have
you bored and you're not maybe not you
know I can like pile drunk or something
be just drinking enough to the next day
wake up and not feel terrific
alright I'm feel bad sure and then you
sleep all day and then you go to the
show and yeah it's easy to get into a
weird bad cycle and it's all you know
it's hard to get out of it because
you're just out there by yourself yeah
it's so boring man yeah even if I have
an opener with me or somebody I'm doing
the show at least we'll go to lunch you
know somebody to eat meals with which is
kind of fun just to talk to on the road
that's amazing me yeah that the road
gets to that point where you're like
[ __ ] at least I got somebody like that
you get excited about the fact that
there's a person to eat lunch with the
guy that's opening for me doesn't go to
lunch of me furious so do you like dude
that's all I got is like us like gonna
talk and hang out right and if they're
like I got it I'm good I'm not hungry
right now I'm like it doesn't even
matter right what you are you better sit
across this table for me I don't know if
you noticed part of the gig
this is pardon that's all the gig did
you go with the you know the headliner
that's what we always do right now do
you rely and then do you realize now
that guys that you opened for
that you would have to go to lunch with
like desperately-needed you because I'm
sure when you're young and you're
opening for people there's still
something exciting about being on yeah I
loved it right I know I get it I I mean
I get it just because I think I'm just
in the doing that you just want to go
eat with someone you just want to go eat
someone and I'm a big I'm a big believer
that hike I think the best way to come
on the material is talking and it's just
talking about where y'all are talking
about the JFK like you know it's like
getting into weird conversations that
right just kind of separate and that's
where you tend a bit fine like something
you like oh that's funny looking you can
find bits and you know I think it's just
good to try to always be funny and be
with comics maybe that's why you sit
alone nude in your apartment doing your
characters to yourself positive it's
like you know trying to develop exactly
what I'm doing
yeah I'm not lonely and mentally ill
hums I'm trying I'm working and I'm
working here nude yeah I am naked a lot
by looking up it wouldn't have a great
view me so does everybody looking in
your window you know that I've do I have
thought of this I'm jerking off on my
couch my open windows they can see from
across the yeah somebody with a
telescope yeah yeah uh-huh they yeah
they can't get mad at you with a
telescope cuz that like if it was just
we're walking by oh yeah first floor
like a store display window yeah that
would be my deck over the
air-conditioner no but I do think that
close the shades on that side I call
them the West shades on the wall it says
who do you say that to myself okay just
me by myself oh man so you get off the
road you're like oh I just want somebody
to eat lunch with and you get off the
road you get you back to your apartment
you're like finally I'm home and I'm
still alone you know I have people I can
go out and eat my friends I go out and
eat with but it's like you just
sometimes I'm like yeah I kind of wish I
lived with somebody and most times I'm
like I'm glad I don't do you walk around
nude in your hotel rooms or is that just
for your apartment no you do your new
times a day sometimes yeah
do the myself a date anybody you know
I'm married oh yeah
do you neighbors think that you have
someone that lives in that house that
new do you ever talk to yourself
the fact that they hear all this talking
a voice is like there's a few guys
living over there like no those are my
character
hear them arguing yeah yeah yeah it's
bad kids they argue with each other out
loud
nope I mean if I'm just screaming about
something alone you scream about things
just alone there's no one there
laughter yeah yeah we gotta talk to this
no one no one's there I don't think I
mean I just I feel like you would not
scream if you were alone no you would
think a lot of people don't right but
you gotta get it out that's true and
that's back to going the victim
conversation I'm just happy you're
getting it out of your system right yes
yeah yeah look I'm just think it's good
that I'm here yes it's essentially that
right right don't worry I got it out of
my system
yeah yeah I'm gonna worry do you bring
your wife with you at all on the road or
no Siobhan she's here now but some you
know they pick the good gigs you know
you know they're like you might go to
Orlando or some you know Disney's near
there or whatever so yeah they go to
some nothing - and it's good I mean you
know that's it gets hard when you I mean
like she's here now you're you have a
routine of even getting ready for shows
where you just want to I don't know have
you music on or yeah take a shower like
get ready like just kind of be and then
when you have a family in your hotel
getting ready while you're getting ready
for that's pretty yeah because you go
from I just want somebody to eat lunch
with - I don't want you guys around all
the time yeah no one needs me in my work
right don't sit in the room looking at
me some guys can just get ready like
they don't have I like to like have you
know like an hour or you can just like
get ready by yourself but yeah some guys
don't care they I feel like some guys
just go to the show and they're like
yeah some guys they just kind of show up
I'm not as worried I don't have enough
time to shower to a nice long shower
just sit there and pretend things are
different it's [ __ ] hot shower just
zone out but I yeah I've been on the
road with you where we've driven
straight from the hotel to the venue and
you went right up on stage I like that
yeah I'm starting to get into that more
when you go to a club like I try to get
there I mean you want to get there at
least right when it starts I would love
for the first guy that hosts to be on
but then I totally get like just lay by
later on you just get there and you
basically walk away you walk right on I
like to go on literally I like to walk
in right as the feature is ending I'm or
if it's a two-person show like you know
right before my the first person goes on
or like when there are 10 minutes into
their 20-minute set I like to get up and
just get the [ __ ] out I don't like to
watch other acts and I want to sit there
it's more time to hang out in the hotel
and not have to be at the venue nude
yeah nude right you don't have to get
you don't have to because it's a venue
you do have to have clothes on yeah
somebody might come in the greenroom you
know it's like anything else man you get
these habits and it's like any other
[ __ ] job you just like a right now
you leave the [ __ ] hotel even though
it's a much more fun job it's always
funny to be in front of people - you're
like like you take a shower in your head
you're like I was in the shower ten
minutes ago
oh my god all these people they know I
get ten minutes ago I was opening my
[ __ ] as water no because the idea is
you know when you're a faint you're just
a fan in the audience like the idea is
that you guys have been backstage for
like you know an hour getting ready like
talking like okay here's what we're
gonna do talking to the warm-up guy
going like okay you go out and do this
and blah blah but no you're just like no
I was asleep obviously I was literally
asleep uh you uh something I've gone on
stage where you're not even really put
together like here in the back of a
greenroom they call you and I have like
you're putting your watch on liking yeah
I'm like you know you're kind of fixing
yourself and now you're just in front of
people yeah that can be kind of
offsetting because you how to feel like
if you don't if you don't have your
walked onstage under the and taking like
the wrong breath and you just feel like
you're up there like like you got you
know you need to like get your breath
back to a rhythm to talk and you're just
kind of off yeah not only did that
happen to me it happened to me last
night I was extremely tired yesterday
and I was in a horrible mood by last
night and I'm on stage and I talked
about something and said it too fast or
too rapidly and I'm like I can't breathe
like I just breathe yeah breathe yeah
that happen to me last night this weird
like those moments where you talk too
much
well you do take that wrong breath or
you like I got a swallow
you can't get the swallow in the breath
you're like what the [ __ ] am i doing
they're all looking at me right now it's
gotta be difficult to take a moment for
yourself when you're on stage in front
of a bunch of people who paid to be
there to look at you well if you're on
TV it's hard like you know thank God
like after a while if it's your audience
they're coming to see you Caroline this
weekend you can just go jeez I had a
[ __ ] up breath there I gotta camp but
you can at least address it as opposed
to a singer can you can't break the
[ __ ] sweet child of mine saying I
gotta breathe properly calm everybody
I'm gonna take a drink of water
do I panic have you know like a big
panic attack yeah I think so no yeah no
do you not really no I mean there's
moments from like it's actually an
irrational thing or will happen on stage
but not very often anymore
yeah there's moments but not rare it's
rare do people I guess now it's
different because people know you that
are going to your shows but when before
when people were just going to a comedy
show and they were going to your show do
you think that they had kind of a they
would listen to you start talking and
have a preconceived notion about what
where you were coming from because your
accent yeah yeah yeah they I learned how
to you know that was a good thing that's
being here and for New York for so long
is you learned how to follow so many
different acts and you learned how to
like I'd always have skip you know I've
been falling Wilson's like you need just
murdering and then you get her next they
used to run a show like it laughs lounge
or something like him in the Rob
Stapleton there's a Rob Stapleton yeah
yeah and they would host and they would
murder
I mean murder hosting and in-between
comics and she mean everybody had to
follow just this unreal set and but I
just remember doing it I knew I learned
how to like just either start a little
awkward or weird or slower just so you
can hear my voice and then get into my
rhythm and then that's just over time I
know how to get I know how to get them
very quickly a big like house a big lie
now it says like the show's probably
peaked so let's just get through it like
you know say even just that is enough to
be like oh this guy's talks different
it's just different and then now I can
go on
smacked and you know where everything's
cool yeah everything's cool but yeah
that's a hard thing I mean usually you
could waste two jokes because that's how
many it takes people to get used to
hearing you there's a new guy on when
all these especially if they're all like
rowdy all used to go hey simmer down
does that work yeah they love it Oh
crowd when you tell them to simmer - the
crowds are like dogs they respond to
discipline you know they want a pat on
the nose good and then go bad bad yeah
following somebody who kills with energy
like I don't I couldn't imagine heaven
they'd be real high animated guy like
just when you gotta go run a set you
like I just want try this joke out and
tired I'm not like I just kind of wanna
you know you what I get mean you have to
go really bring it like oh god that
would be so tight it's [ __ ]
exhausting yeah and sometimes you just
don't feel like doing it so I just want
to go on just talk you know nice and
easy
yeah I would hate to be a character like
golly emo Philips seems like a hard
talking about you know I mean onstage no
chip is one thing just laughs come from
your character at the end of your sight
yes they do
ChIP chip person is by far literally
doing a character with a costume and
everything he's warmed up by then by the
time he gets that Jim Norton has become
chip cheaper since warm-up comic yeah
yeah I really am I'm the I'm the [ __ ]
I forget the name of the basketball team
that played with the Globetrotters but
that's what Jim Norton is nationals at
the real baseball yeah just somebody
just somebody to prop up chip ship
person that that really is all it is
yeah but I don't know my immediate
character like with high energy we just
got to go on and have all the Washington
Generals generals that was it yeah did
you notice any like I don't know
probably not difference but any feedback
from the Netflix half-hour
oh yeah it's night and day it really it
is it's that big it's it's that big and
it's you know I mean I've done all these
tonight shows another big one serious
and
like a nice Pandora Spotify that kind of
stuff you mean your comedy getting
played I'm like yeah yeah that's that
would have been maybe number one if it
before Netflix that was so much
hour-by-hour Pandora Spotify like all
that stuff but it's like that that was
people just listening to comedy how
economy is a really good thing to listen
to if you're even driving around at home
like not even for like a lot of guys
driving trucks officer listen but just
people driving around like I listen to
it some like it's just nice to hear and
it changes a lot it's different guy it's
like so he's you not to be committed and
then but then when Netflix came out I
mean it's not even close I mean the
numbers jump just pretty wildly enough
to like you know before it I'm you're
kind of curious to see how many people
come see you and you can fill it it may
be half you know and then the other
people don't really know you and then
then didn't they go into those times you
like oh everybody you know there's been
certain clubs that go to you and you're
like everybody here knows they're all
hired from it yes
and that's a that's all brand new that's
happening to me now I can go to some
clubs and still maybe it doesn't you
know not fully happening and but you
know Caroline's is they there be
hopefully a lot of people there and like
it's just a way you you got to learn how
to even be able to do that you gotta
learn how to like how do you go out in
front like you know so many people work
at know you so there you go out and
there I don't know it's like they're
excited to see it's a weird thing we're
so used to going out and I assume no one
knows who I am
so you that's how I first operate from
and now you gotta operate from a place
not you know we're just many of them
they do know you and then you're like oh
it's a relief it could be the perception
changes from [ __ ] I have to win them
over to when you walk out and go [ __ ] I
don't want to lose them yeah like but
it's still the same thing like you know
like I you know you're gonna do good and
you've got the benefit of the doubt with
your own audience like you know they
know I'm funny and they're here to see
me so if I'm funny it'll work I don't
have to worry about like oh no is that
joke too rough or they're gonna groan at
that or walk out but it's almost like I
don't want to mail it in either like I
want to at least have them go like you
know he's at least giving us new
material he's trying to do something
that he didn't earn more pressure like
in that sense cuz you got a key
you gotta keep this audience and you
keep in you guys still be growing it and
keep it and yeah it's Netflix's I mean
there it's yeah it's oh it's wild like
what's going on
you know I mean they're doing it with
all that stand up and they're buying
everything they are buying a lot of
stand up yes it is really interesting I
was thinking about it because at first
when they started really spending a lot
of money on the giant a list names I was
like that kind of sucks for the people
who aren't a list because it's like you
know you get distracted by everything
going on over here how do you find the
other specials but putting all the young
guys in that packet where the comedians
now becomes a series like that that
brand almost becomes this thing of
whenever there's a season it's like oh I
love when Netflix does this and then it
just gives exposure to all you guys yeah
yeah and he goes back I was on season
one no they just did season two and then
I did someone's told me at the end of
season two he just rolls into mine
like if you if you let it keep going
were you the first episode I was the
first episode we were just talking to
Joe list who's the first episode of
season two about how good what a great
placement that is yes I told you know
you're just experimenting like I don't
really have much time but let me see
what this comedians thing is yeah
totally I mean I told Joe I was like I
was first and I was like dude
Wendy cuz when he told me he got it I
was like just I don't know if it could
happen but I would tell everybody to try
to get first can you can't do what do
you how do you get it do you campaign
for it as it just happened no I think
your agents are something or someone's
saying it or like what you know maybe
some people are some people aren't you
know the age it's that became a big deal
I think to get first like after ours
came out because then what I was told is
because I'm like the minded good because
the everybody's watching the first one
sure so then you know the agents and
stuff knew that so that was a big deal
so when whoever would get it there you
know right they would really like go
after they go well you need to be first
and yeah because it is I mean people
will definitely it's easy to watch the
one thirty minutes is the new you I
think comics should I mean I still like
an hour special but I would not comics
throughout half hour specials the
highest level of comedian I don't think
it's a bad thing
not right now soon 3040 minutes like
even 40 yeah it's consumable it's easier
for
us to come up with the jokes when you
tour on the road you will always have
another half-hour that no one's seen and
you can just be moving and shifting that
around and that is true I mean the hour
was the HBO thing because they have
blocks of programming so they have to
fill I think 56 minutes they have four
minutes of promo on time after you have
to chop your [ __ ] special up and if
it Netflix doesn't give a [ __ ] I mean
I'm 38 52 I whatever I mean it's just
running people just watch it when they
want to watch it so yeah that's a great
point make 45 minutes could be a good
time for special 30 minutes good time
for special I like the idea of putting
out like 30 minutes every you know
whatever year or two and then maybe
every like five or six years put out an
hour and then it's an event that's just
became that that just became the model
an hour but you're right there's no
reason not to do it like 45 would be the
30 or 45 like 30 could be quick but it
is it depends on how long you've waited
she like Chappelle came back and it is I
don't want to see I want to see one hour
because it's it's an event so I wish I'm
not I like that idea of it to like just
sitting back waiting and then I mean you
get right now in the meantime you can
put out those half hours that's not
that's just like hey it's just a little
taste of what I'm doing right now
you're not like here it is here's the
presentation I I think you should I
think we should do that I think guys you
did 45 at least like it's just no one
wants to I think you got to be under an
hour like I feel like if someone looks
at something it says sixty two minutes
that's enough to make you go I don't
know it's a whole thing maybe yeah I
don't have an hour like I mean I think
about 30 minutes I mean I mean tens you
watch the 30 minute show you can sit
down and watch the 30 minute show like
it's nothing like you know especially
because you're like I'm trying to find
out what's happening with these Rajneesh
people today too like I got a lot going
on that's specially that's very good
that documentary again I'm in episode
three what's it called wild wild country
wild country I heard weather yesterday
it's very he's got a way it gets better
with each episode it's so cool yeah it
does get more and more like oh it's like
a cult thing yeah yeah yeah I heard
about him Oregon yeah I could be Nicole
you would I don't think I would but I
think I could easily get swept into one
anybody if I wasn't even near it Harding
are you very very are you or you just
like to fit in or you gullible I'm going
I can be I'm not super
but I can if you get me by myself I
won't I don't want to be mean and say no
to you yeah I would just be I would just
like yes I'll just live with these
people I also think that anybody who has
had as eaten at the Time Square
Applebee's many times even though
they've lived in New York good point
could join a cult oh yeah I would ask
other people when I first said have you
ever been times worth because it's just
it's a walk around the group is well sit
there have you ever been Time Square
what
it's a familiarity it's a comfortable in
this you know what to expect nothing's
gonna shock you like this is what we one
day I think you'll be shocked but up
until there be one thing that you make
whoa yeah kill ourselves see that
cyanide-laced boneless buffalo wings I
watched the whole the Oklahoma City
bombing they did it well there's to the
Unabomber there's a great Unabomber
thing on Netflix that was on is it a
show or documentary it's a show okay
sure and I think the guy was in
promoting that ownership rate the FBI
director yeah the cop or did he play the
media guy and I played the cop okay yeah
it was great and dead I didn't really
excited know a lot about that that
happened you know I mean I was a kid I
was a kid a teenager it happened late
time so about it
I didn't know what like yeah this I
didn't know a ton about it and so it was
interesting just to learn you know yeah
this crazy thing that was like he's
sitting in two buildings you know what
was great and it's on the Paramount
network so I think if to get the
paramount Network app and then putting
like your cable login or whatever but
they did a Waco show it was like six
episodes and they had the guy from
Friday Night Lights playing David Koresh
and Michael Shannon's on it it's like
the hostage negotiator guy but they go
over the whole Waco Branch Davidians
thing over the course of six episodes I
wish it had been longer than six
episodes but it was it was really good
you watch this guy like you watch what
starts they do a good job of getting you
sympathetic to David Koresh and being
like yeah it's just a guy who loves
Jesus like I go and hang out and love
Jesus with him and how it deteriorates
into this you know crazy guy I would see
I could get I think I get myself in a
cult and I do think I'd be
one of the first to go we I don't think
we should be here like so and that's how
you figured out but I would definitely
get myself in right and then just
literally find the right person but I
don't do you think we should be here
right now you go like at first you'd be
like this is a cool place man yeah good
people hanging out like this is all good
and then you get that realization like
are we arena I think we want structure
too I always saying as a comic there's
so many times like you're like I just
wanna get a riding gig where I have to
go to this place 9:00 to 5:00 and like
you're just like you know you get in
comedy cuz you can do whatever you want
and then like I don't want to do
whatever I want I want to go here at
this time did this time we need lunch at
this time and right because your life
you know when the check is coming ya
know like if this is my life it's a
regular life and I'm not like you know
yeah I can make no plans too far out
because you just never know right you
got in your head what if I get something
and there always be something sure maybe
it's not as big as you think it's gonna
be but I can make it as big as always
something there's always something
that's gonna come up and you go alright
well guess I'll go do that and I won't
you know it doesn't matter if I don't go
to this guy's funeral right tell my mom
he's already dead my mom has to go with
it yeah yeah that's why I like radio I
mean it's a real it's a steady gig it's
like one of those things where I always
got something to do
that's the worst fears of performers you
like a [ __ ] what if I have nothing to do
yeah what do I have no work like I said
I'm not relevant I mean nothing like and
we should all feel irrelevant sometimes
but if you have somewhere to go and
there are people who are relying on you
to be there at least you feel like
alright I'm doing something Yeah right I
have to I have to be there people will
notice if I'm not there I do get paid to
be there I let you know there's it makes
you feel like it at least I'm alive
yeah you they should do it it's nice
much yeah some guys have [ __ ] nothing
going on some guys are dead they are
physically dead you some people are dead
yeah that's not a place you want to be
they would be here if they weren't so
think so no it's my way that's roarsome
no I'm in just in June Oh army are even
in this room they'd all be sitting right
there with tonight Norman Reedus
and Wendy Williams I like Wendy way what
do you do I first said I don't think I
heard you think you don't any like but
she's pretty nice and great yeah I think
she's like I'd like you give good heart
you know like really roots for you and I
think so I think so I don't know I and I
am this is judging off I mean minutes
that I've seen it could be a [ __ ]
tornado really yeah I think she's still
on yet is she had to she had a sickness
that made her collapse remember what
said yes personally I feel that she
faked it she didn't fake it she did take
a week or I think she did take three
weeks off and she wanted to guest host
so she took two weeks with best-of and
by the third week the network was like
you got to do something so they had
Jerry O'Connell as her fill-in host cuz
I guess she likes him as a guest it is
really weird to you know this show is
built around Wendy Williams this
charismatic black woman who's talking
about you know a lot of black culture
and celebrity gossip and stuff like that
and Jerry O'Connell is the guy that
that's why she got Jerry because he's
totally opposite of right right she
didn't want them to watch someone to go
well you know what she's doing it for
but she's doing it for one tenth of
Wendy's price you just had a Troy in the
Statue of Liberty it's just like that's
so smart it's just fun you can you can
you can watch Jerry O'Connell for a week
talk about Basketball Wives and like oh
this is fun and wacky but yeah there's
no risk of him taking over there she
goes yeah that's real down she goes look
at her alright listen to the volume I uh
I think it's just I think there might be
a voice over there she goes look at
those eyes go crazy wow that's crazy and
then you know I was watching her like I
mean weeks after this had already
happened might have even been months
after this had happened and she would do
her monologues where she's sitting there
and I mean she'd be making googly crazy
eyes at the camera like I was going
there something what do you think it is
I don't know she got super skinny and
she was making crazy eyes and didn't
feel like she was pretty not eating
really following her sentences that she
was saying you know like she was reading
off the teleprompter but like really
weird pauses and in in where she'd take
her breaths and stuff and just didn't
seem like she even knew what she was
reading but the audience was like
reacting like crazy then the reading
assignment applause
wasn't she going through a divorce or
there was allegations that her husband
was cheating or something that [ __ ]
her up but she wasn't eating
yeah there's allegations that her
husband Graves disease travis has
cheated on her
they said Graves disease what is Graves
disease it's it's gravely serious Jim
this is serious it sounds worse than
apart meaning it's the one you want for
that but there have been those that have
speculated that she's on drugs too oh
she uh some people have speculated it
well maybe yes so uh I think we had our
we had our affairs
our mayor Nashville's mayor and I call
with it Oh trust me they're obsessed if
that reporter of Williams Williams he's
the great mr. Bain we talked about
that's him that's how he talks mr. baby
we love Phil yet you know about buddy
that opens for me as a comic and he
worked at channel 5 for 20 years as a
producer can he get us in touch with
Phil Williams we want those Williams
yeah yeah we love Phil Williams we watch
all kinds of Phil Williams news reports
on the show we watched the whole your
whole mayor drama yeah we ain't no more
an under we covered the entire system
yeah oh and down because we were first
just obsessed with Phil Williams yeah
then we became obsessed with this story
the Phil Williams really very house you
[ __ ] up the state trooper in the
cemetery what yeah what a good egg well
India you know what's funny is uh it's a
weird thing with them because they they
no one like everybody down there like
have you seen you her husband
Oh guys looks like Jesse Ventura regular
there's like negative aspects none of
the pot not big and strong or anything
like that just the negative side yeah
sure
there's like Southern Christian moms
that will when they hear this story they
go whoa you're seeing her husband I was
like sitting there I was I'm out I told
like like my family I was telling my
family friends I go this is crazy cuz
ya'll I go can you imagine if it was a
if it's flip-flopped and the husband's
cheating on the wife and the guy goes
well you seen his wife just kind of
train wreck that's in everybody's doing
that to this guy no one respects this
guy no it's I've just never heard women
just totally turn on like nobody cares
about her husband nobody cares it all
they do they just lost a son yeah
they've more worried about that they
don't can't rent the husband no they
don't they're not yeah there's been
weird Savoy and her son like they were
saying to when her son they had a
somewhere else and I God they didn't go
to the funeral hours together or one of
them maybe was something else they had
in another state the dad probably went
to the funeral and the mom was probably
[ __ ] the bodyguards yeah she's
probably taken what they did yeah but
it's a I'm just blown away how open and
it's I mean they're not even like they
don't say it like quite it's an open
thing to be like well have you seen your
husband I mean he's a real doofus that
funny and they just so [ __ ] the other
guy I think they are still together
I would hope hurry up yeah yeah but
separated yeah but you don't want once
you lose the DA I don't and I'm not
completely positively separated I could
be wrong let's find that out if she's
still dying in the trooper or not cuz he
lost everything too much once you lose
the job his wife broke divorced yeah
yeah
which is crazy she's a guy don't want
just Megan baring like thing and
everything why should we ask her once
you lose the job though you both lost
the jobs and the marriages are over you
kind of lost the excitement of a lot of
the reason that you were doing what you
were doing right possibly but then again
you're like alright well I don't have
the gig I don't have the gig she won't
[ __ ] me he won't [ __ ] alright well I
guess it's us might as well you might as
well stay together but I got to be
honest the Mayor was hotter when she was
the mayor she was yeah you know that's
the matter twice did you hi sugar person
she's good yeah she's like a [ __ ] I
think it's hard to she's a mayor so
everything starts with that so even like
how she looks at anything today your
mayor
yeah like you're when you look at in
your head I mean she doesn't look good
she's not a bad-looking woman like but
like you started with this is a mayor
I'm looking at right yeah so no matter
what she's gonna be hot
hottest chick in the world she's like
that's a mayor's jennifer aniston base
that's true of mayors right it's
unreliable I've never eaten the mayor's
[ __ ] would you yes we love to eat the
mayor's [ __ ] they had a she had a
security yeah a different security guy
outside her house in the sink I took a
picture and I like after all this happen
it someone's like here we go again
someone said that like she's already
she's already into it with the next guy
like he just shows up she divorced her
insecurities his her The Bodyguard is
yeah his wife she's his wife had enough
of his malarkey yeah yeah yeah that's
why she was very nice I liked her like
that
when I met her she's very nice and look
at you know what I wonder if the husband
is just kind of resigned himself to this
is what life's gonna be please don't
divorce me
yeah pathetic way to be well that's what
everybody would say I mean yeah I van
they just openly I mean these are like
Christian southern moms just calling
them and are like just yeah like they're
not you know and just like bull seen
your husband these women that you're
like I don't think you care about looks
I don't think you're you know have you
seen a lot of your husband's this isn't
Christian of you to be yeah he's a prat
he's a professor at Vanderbilt yeah boy
the husband Oh any students any of you
have any questions I got one not about
my wife yeah well hands go down he's
here and he they spend thousands of
dollars throughout their affair they kid
was 22 and he died in Denver of a drug
overdose that's so tragic shipwright
blamin she's babe well she was very open
about all that she talked to everybody
about it and all like that's that's a
lot of stuff that a lot of people like
about her is like she was very but maybe
she had to because she was having a huge
affair all right what'd she do you said
no or that's that baby I think so I
think it's been a little bit I don't
know you know yeah it's one of those
things when it comes out to you let you
want to go like how many people knew
like how many people in that ranks know
yeah they haven't had to [ __ ] in the
cemetery every morning that's like the
Tiger Woods uh thing like they when they
talked to those girl likes turned
to house-train could talk those girls
and they and that one of them was like I
don't know how this has to come out like
because he would be at Vegas like openly
sitting with other women right something
like how is this for a long time
it's almost like people just agree like
oh we all know that this happens but
we're not gonna say anything and then
one person isn't in the agreement so the
one person finally says something and
then everybody's allowed to jump on like
okay right I think I've encouraged him
and dumped him for cheating now
allegedly is not your friend you know
the new girlfriend dumped one of them
did yeah unfortunately and he's like I
don't I can't wrap his head around think
is what I don't understand what's that
like that's not good for easy is he
playing in the mass now it's today but
it crispy exciting you're excited about
the year a golf fan I'm a golf fan so
yeah and the Masters is pretty special
masters is like yeah it's very
old-school with a lot of they're even
beliefs and then but they're pricey if
you go there they sell like hot dogs for
like 75 cents or something her dollar
it's these prices from the 50s and so
time get yes just like don't they don't
J so it's it's it's pretty stupid you
like off you go yeah I don't play golf
and then I love playing and then I'm
watching it is great to you yeah her
name is uh the extra often wants to
break the NDA she had his ex-girlfriend
looks just like his ex-wife no she's a
little thicker but she's sexy okay but
the new one night perversion of his
ex-wife I don't mind that yes yeah wait
is that wife wants to break to know
there's an extra flex trough with a big
fat ass here's a nice rump imitate what
his ex-wife is good for she's talked
about nothing I don't think that I know
how like I haven't seen any or anything
she's just sit there and like moved on
with her life I know she got paid but
how many all talk everybody always talks
like this girls already like dated him
for 20 minutes and she wants to spill
her and spill her guts on everything in
her ex-wife is just sit there quietly
that X&Y ton of money
she was pretty the last thing that she's
gonna want to see those is the
ex-husband now he's dating somebody that
looks just like you except has a fat ass
I wonder if she cares at this point cuz
she's probably dating someone else she's
got [ __ ] 30 or 50 million dollars or
more which
she just spends a couple months counting
her money in singles yeah she's probably
like [ __ ] him
I think it's like a hundred million
dollars she's probably done [ __ ] him
anyway yeah after all that embarrassing
[ __ ] came out was a 2009 now she's been
divorced for a while I remember my wife
texted me when this happened and said he
was in a car accident and he was a guy
Tiger Woods is like again he and Michael
Jordan went to people like if I ever met
I wouldn't know what to say yes and when
I met my heart dropped when she checked
I read that I was on the I was a mirror
I was on the back of like a Southwest
plane and I just read it and I'm just
like like you're like what I call I call
it as like whatever I get the feeling
numb brain we have to wait Billy in this
plane we're gonna get out of here what's
a direwolf is in a car accident and be
like fine those do you like Tiger Woods
for his golfer for his extracurriculars
I like for his golf I'd like you know I
was in before now so when the old it
when all the [ __ ] starts becoming
public yeah do you go like I don't know
if I like this guy as much no yes no
yeah I don't yeah it's not yeah like I
don't care about yeah
it's hunting it's hard to get offended
as a comedian right like it's hard to
out of people to get fit you just don't
care you're like I don't care what you
did a guy dumping loads is never gonna
offend a comedian why do you [ __ ]
Perkins waitress with no condom here on
out you know yeah you like that it's
weird waitresses right you're like dude
you're a billionaire and you're like it
like a Denny's and like yeah in like in
these real relationships kind of with
these people man
what a thrill it was for that Perkins
waitress right getting the same thing no
one had my Tiger Woods yeah see this
this way yeah yeah you never guess what
happened
maybe she tell someone then they
wouldn't they didn't yeah no but he
would never fly on that he would fly on
like a coach and never never gave him
like any kind of money at all like that
I mean not even like $1000
he was very cheap he's like Michael
Jordan in that sense but that we find
coach oh yeah you get girls that's
what's crazy too is like that's a guy
wants to get caught you like your name
treating them well easily like great so
they stay on your side it's crazy but
you get girls who haven't like
experienced a lot like you get it
Perkins waitress who doesn't even know
she's like Oh coach Aaron
my ticket that's probably costing
eighteen hundred dollars yeah it never
really flown right she's like exactly
little seats so if I get to talk to two
people that's all this food is free yeah
yeah can I get two hands of coke
trying to tell the person next I'm going
to visit Tiger Woods they don't believe
maybe it's smart they don't believe in
like because if she was would she be in
coach and exactly what you think she'd
be in first class that's what her
husband says that lady's an idiot right
and maybe it's genius genius yeah he
does a show I die my Tiger once he was
Joe I did but many years he was I was
opening for dice in Vegas and he came
with an entourage I by ran out at the
end before he left and met him briefly
and he signed my dump business cards
part in 1997-98 was he fine was he and I
said he's not yeah it was you are
awesome I did that joke it was a joke
but he was really nice he was very
pleasant that's probably what's
happening he was all cute in late 90s he
was [ __ ] spill and [ __ ] all over the
[ __ ] tri-state her but dice didn't
give a [ __ ] that was the dice ilysm he's
like the least starstruck person I've
ever know he doesn't give a [ __ ] because
they will I remember what they're going
like Tiger might come back and it goes
who cares
just give the [ __ ] he never cared who's
in the audience
it's amazing that's great yeah I wish I
were to talk to him longer tiger yeah I
just said was brief 10 seconds yeah yeah
I was tired
well dice would let him come back well
he would've but he didn't care if he did
yeah like you know I'm sure if Tiger
would have been allowed to come back but
thanks wasn't way did he know he was oh
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah so you want Tiger
to win the Masters yeah it would be
great I mean it'd be that's not gonna
happen or it could happen
I can happen YZ he's coming I came in
second and Inter minority of is Jerry's
playing really good he's favored Robert
has rep says no way it would be a lot I
mean would be an unreal story if he does
but the Vegas had him favored it's not
it we're not in a position where we have
been where his back hurts and I don't
even know if he's gonna finish
he's been playing good and but yeah it's
it's very unlikely
how long since he won a tournament 2015
maybe okay does he start is he still
gonna break the record or no now he's
for four majors away
tying Jack Nicklaus so it's you know II
can still do it I mean these guys win
majors if he does it he will be the
oldest to win majors
no one's ever won them I forget how old
they were but they're but no one's ever
won them you know so if he wins on me
he'll have to be 40 he's 42 so he'll
probably be maybe 50 you know but guys
playing till 5060 then they play till
they're 80 yeah so he's won the Masters
before he's warned you yeah all right
Travis I felt like you acted weird like
you're about to do a joke on me I
thought someone was boggling as he
wanted before him just didn't know if he
won the Masters oh yeah no yeah he's won
a bunch of stuff he's known as one of a
good golfer yeah yes yeah he's won via I
mean the most major I mean he has like
cuts so if you make if you get cut in a
tournament so you play first two rounds
and then if you don't meet if you're on
the top like 60 or 70 people you get cut
and you're have to leave and he's made
cuts it's like two hundred and are
almost two hundred and eighty something
times no one's even close like the
people that are closest to him in a row
that are like a hundred maybe oh it's
like a record that's like take a Cal
Ripken thing yeah yeah I mean it's wild
no it's great yeah we know one's ghost
Wayne Gretzky another guy that has a
it's awesome